نجوا بمعجزه من بين تلك الانقاض في سوريا
اثرى نوبه زلزال مدمر لكنهم في امس الحاجه
للمساعدات بكافه اشكالها وسط مساع امميه
لادخال الاعانه برا الى سوريا التي تمتلك
ما لا يقل عن عشره معابر حدوديه حيث تترقب
كل من الولايات المتحده والمانيا تنفيذ
النظام السوري قرار فتحي مع بريبه بالسلام
والراعي لمرور الاعانات الانسانيه الا ان
الانقسامات السياسيه قد تعرقل جهود
الاغاثه ففي شمال غربي البلاد تسيطر هيئه
تحرير الشام على محافظه ادلب كما ان هناك
منطقتين تسيطر عليهما عده فصائل تدعمهما
تركيا ابرزها الجيش الوطني السوري اضافه
الى منطقه الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرقي
سوريا التي يتزعمها الاكراد بقياده قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه اما دمشق وبقيه المدن
فهي خاضعه للنظام السوري
ومن ابرز ما عبر سوريا من جهه تركيا باب
الهوى الخاضع لسيطره هيئه تحرير الشام اما
معبر باب السلام والحمام وجرابلس والراعي
فترتبط بين تركيا ومناطق في شمال وشرقي
محافظه حلب تسيطر عليها فصائل المعارضه
المدعومه من قبل انقره
كل نقاط العبور تلك باعبائها وازماتها
وحجم النزاع بين المسيطرين عليها دفعت
مسؤولا بلجنه الانقاذ الدوليه للقول ان
الزلازل لا تعترف بتلك الحدود